well between that area if you recall
areas just about how much 2d space
something takes right length is about
one dimension like backwards and
forwards or up and down but area always
requires two dimensions there's an up
and down and there's also a left and
right so when we describe these units
for area we need to have both of them in
mind so for example if you could label
both the up-down and the horizontal she
said verticals your know the vertical
and the horizontal legs let's for
example label them 1 meter how do we
work out the area of this shape you go
ahead
very good we're multiplying these two
together now just like before I
emphasize the unit's here with Krishan
right units are so important when we
multiply these two legs together we
multiply the units as well we get 1 from
the numbers 1 times 1 but instead of
saying meters what's my unit for area
here here very good meters squared or
alternatively you might like to put this
in another color we sometimes say one
square meter because it's literally in
the shape of a square now this is one
square meter but you of course have all
these other metric units here's what I'd
like you to do underneath where you've
drawn your square I'd like you to list
out as many metric units for length that
you can think of them maybe we just
start at a millimeter cuz I know you
could get as as small as you like after
that like micrometers and nanometers and
likely let's just start at millimeters I
think that's fine we can see millimeters
after one millimeter I'd like you to
write as many of the next units that you
can increasing in size and maybe we can
stop at a kilometer see can you do the
ones in between and I'll give you a
minute or so to try and complete that
list we're looking at the metric units
for length
I think there should be two missing okay
what's after millimeters yeah they
discuss enemy it is go ahead David
what's have to say to you just Amina
which we actually already had on the
board and then I went straight to a
kilometer I'm sort of you might have
thought oh I know if there's an extra
one in here what happens where you've
got about two and a half centimeters
about two and a half what what we call
that we call that an inch but there's a
reason why I have not included this on
the list inches are not a metric unit is
anyone remember what they call not all
system inches and feet starts of an eye
Imperial very good so I've not included
them on this this Louise there's a good
question if we had a deci meter what do
you think that name suggests you where
do you think it should fit so he'll do
between here and here does decimeter
sound like it's ten seven minutes hmm
this is interesting isn't it
we know Dec like a decade or a decagon
that's ten but some people saying no is
somewhat it suggests where else it could
go not here where do you think you
should go here between here and here
because this is like meters and the deci
meter like 10m so you think it should be
10 of these 10 meters 10 meters so you
reckon there should be in here some
people record should be in here general
Spector you should go elsewhere
once it wait hold on between here it's
this way you should put it that's where
you'd put them huh yeah I'm gonna yes I
do anything 10 equals 1 decimeter let's
think about this for a second we
actually have enough information on the
board I think to work out where it's
gonna be I haven't told you the answer
yet when we say a centimeter centimeter
let's actually use can we write the
whole word 1 centimeter
what does that mean yeah yes yep
yeah very good this is actually kind of
where I was going you've sort of
preempted what I was going to write one
meter is just like a dollar right it's
100 of these right do you agree so to
take a centimeter it's like taking where
it is there it is taking my meter right
and then I divide it into how many
portions 500 and Mackey's juice that's
one centimeter down there right so if
that's what a centimeter means what do
you think that sounds like dividing up a
meter into one how many chunks not a
hundred chunks probably 10 chunks 1 2 3
4 how big would each of those chunks be
if they were 10 all the way across I
think it would be 10 centimeters as so
they're suggesting it's not because it's
10 of those it's because it's dividing
this into Tim does that make sense
hmm okay so we started to do this we
said a meter equals 100 centimeters
what's a centimeter in terms of the
previous unit yeah go ahead just go very
good ten millimeters and then last time
down the bottom what's a kilometer how
many meters are there image a thousand
very good and that's because kilo means
a thousand just like a kilogram is a
thousand grams okay
now these are the units for length but
now beside these if we have a think
about when they have area for example
one square centimeter or one square
meter or one square kilometer okay you
have to be really careful with these
right cuz you know how for example to go
for a meter two centimeters we
multiplied by 100 right well let's have
a look at this here can we have a look
back at our square we labeled it as a
meter and a meter
what would the dimensions of the square
be in centimeters according to what
we've just written yeah 100 centimeters
and that would also be a hundred
centimeters so now when we do what we
suggest at the beginning by multiplying
height and our width what number are we
going to get out
when we get one hundred and hundred what
are you get ten thousand that ten
thousand square centimeters right so you
multiply not by a hundred by a hundred
squared what about in a square
centimeter how many millimeters squared
will be in that thing
hmm have a think about this for a second
yeah Christian what do you think 100
millimeters where did that 100 come from
think about it think about it yeah say
hey where's the 100 coming from yeah
very good see this 10 it's 10
millimeters by 10 millimeters that's the
10 times 10 gives us 100 let's do the
last one here in the list a square
kilometer this is really big hairy 1
million is that what you're saying and
can you see where we got the million
from I did the million come from it's
huge it's a thousand times a thousand
yeah now these links here as you can see
sorry these areas I should have said
they get bigger and be are really really
fast
so actually it's not quite decimeters
but we do sneak one more metric unit and
it goes right in here does anyone know
what it's called it's a weird one yeah
henna a hectare one hectare we
abbreviate this just by saying H a I
don't know why we don't use H E because
well anyway that's okay does anyone know
I mean how do you put your hand up
pretty quick does anyone know how big a
hectare is yeah 10,000 so if you were to
draw a hectare as a square what would
the lengths of the sides be to get to
10,000 we actually already have 10,000
on the board yeah a hundred meters by a
hundred meters very good so this is on
an area that often gets used when you're
measuring things like say in agriculture
you don't really care about how meters
are in your field you care about how
much stuff you can fit on it that's an
area question so hectares are frequently
used in places like that